In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon from May 22, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Basilicus.
On the 22nd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Basilicus.
The nephew of Saint Theodore Tyran, Saint Basilicus was tortured with Saint Eotropus and Clonicus
at Amsia, but to his great distress he did not enjoy the glory of martyrdom with them, being
sent back to prison after their execution.
As he was weeping and lamenting in his dungeon, Christ appeared to him and assured him that
he had written his name in his kingdom, and that he would not be in the least inferior
to his companions.
When he bade him, go and say goodbye to his family.
At daybreak, Basilicus saw that the doors of the prison were open, and, leaving with
his guards, he traveled to his native village of Kumiala, where he said farewell to his mother
and Kinsfolk and begged them to remain faithful to Christ and to pray that he would do the
same.
He returned to the prison of Amsia just at the moment when the new governor, the cruel and
terrible Agrippa, had assembled the nobles of the city for a banquet to celebrate his
appointment.
As they had spoken to him of Saint Basilicus, he ordered that he be transferred to Kumana
Pontus with the other Christians to be judged.
He was violently hauled out of prison, bound with heavy chains, and iron sandals were nailed
to his feet.
Throughout the journey, the escort of thirteen soldiers beat him, so that the road was a wash
with his blood.
When they stopped in the village of Dachwazara, they bound Basilicus, his hands tied behind
his back, to a long dead plain tree, while they enjoyed a meal at the home of Troinea, the
village headwoman.
After the saint's prayer, an earthquake suddenly occurred, producing a great bang that sent
all the idle revelers to the floor.
When they stood up, they saw to their amazement that the plain tree had become green again,
and that a spring of pure water was flowing at the blessed saint's feet.
Seeing this sight, Troinea and all her household believed in Christ, and the saint having delivered
the possessed and healed the sick, converted not only a large number of the village people,
but also the soldiers of his escort.
From there on, holding their prisoner in great respect, they took off his chains before setting
out again on their journey.
In every place along the route Basilicus worked miracles and brought about conversions.
He refused to take any food, satisfied as he was by prayer, and the grace of Christ within
him.
Arriving in Khamana, they found a grip other there, who ordered that the martyr be taken
without delay to the temple of Apollo to offer sacrifice.
The soldiers of the local garrison struck him and mocked his faith in an invisible God, but
the saint, filled with bold assurance, replied that, although God cannot be seen according
to his nature, he manifests himself spiritually, according to the energy of his grace, in
so far as it is possible for human intelligence to comprehend him, and he works many wonders
through the intermediary of those he judges worthy to receive him.
When he was taken before the magistrate in the temple and asked to sacrifice, he replied
that he would always offer a sacrifice of praise to God.
A grippa asked him the name of this God, and he replied, my God is inexpressible, imperceptible,
indescribable, and indivisible.
The names which are given to him in Holy Scripture are, Father, Almighty, Lord and God,
King of kings and Lord of hosts, Savior, Merciful, Compassionate, Long-Suffering, and Rich
in Mercy.
This is the God to whom I offer a sacrifice of praise.
The governor angrily retorted, sacrifice in the name of whichever God you will, but
sacrifice, and let us be done with this.
Raising his hands to heaven Basilica sent up an ardent prayer to God for the destruction
of the idols, and immediately a fire descended from heaven, setting fire to the temple and
reducing the state of Apollo to ashes.
The governor rushed out of the burning building, and the whole town was greatly disturbed by
this event.
Regaining his composure but seething with rage, a grippa made the saint who had been miraculously
protected from the flames, leave the temple, and then accused him of practicing magic.
Basilicus replied that this was not a question of magical contrivance, but the power of God,
who had so acted to prove that pagan gods are nothingness and illusion.
Seeing the immovable firmness of the martyr, the magistrate pronounced the sentence of death.
Basilicus was taken outside the town to a place named Discarus, where he was beheaded.
A Christian bought his body from the executioners and built a church at Comana in which he
gave him worthy burial.
It was in this church on the 13th of September in the year 407 that Saint John Chrysostom
on the way to his last exile had a vision of Saint Basilicus who comforted him and promised
him that they would be reunited on the following day.
The next day, after having clothed himself in white robes and having received holy communion,
the holy hierarchy gave his soul into God's hands.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us, and save us.